we're going to develop this other form
alongside general for and gradient
intercept form we're going to develop
together point grateful here's what I'm
going to do I'm going to notice right
the gradient is important to this right
gradient by definition in this fraction
of rise burger run where this now when
you have a look at the question you've
got all these pieces that go into this
equation
think about it you've got gradient I can
just put that in a pan just put the
numbering I'm going to work out a gray
outside rather run what's the actual X&Y
stuff that belongs here well I have to
write y2 minus y1 very good that's like
how are you were how how you come from
Oman is the same quantity but you're
looking horizontally rather than
vertically okay so in other words I need
two points to know X on y1 x2 y2 now
look I have one of the points right here
okay so I'm going to write down over
here let's call the first point x1 y1
let put this point it's one of the
points on my life 90 of 3 comma 1 now I
need another point this is the tricky
bit don't know what this one appointment
can be in fact it can be a whole bunch
of different things so therefore I'm
going to give it a label and says
alright I'm not sure what it is I use
prones words whenever I'm not sure what
a number is I'm just changing it
slightly because I need to have these
two anymore as you'll see in a second so
here's the idea
I'm going this point so I just applied
it on this one of the given I don't know
this point so I'm supply perennials
because that's what I use variables but
when I don't know the value now ivory
watch what happens
this em okay so I'm going to substitute
all this stuff that I know in Turkey art
and see what comes out
that's hentai that's just too isn't it
right hand side what am I going to write
on the new bread instead of y2 minus y1
have a look at my values over here I
think I'm going to write Y - there's my
1 there isn't it
that's why 1 1 do you hear that
do you see how I've used these pieces
here substitute I can do the same thing
for the denominator I'm going to get my
ass take away negative 3 right into
doubling inside or what attack watch
after no okay now this is really good
because this is a whole lot more simpler
even though I have to think about a
second because it is this is a whole lot
more simple than all of this this is
like always got some value you've got to
go round and round find a value put it
back in if you have a look at this as I
rub this out what would you do to
simplify this slide down here what would
be the next thing you have a look pick
up your pen and have a go I'm trying to
get to something nice and simple done
yet what would you do to that equation
to both side to start to make it a bit
leader write something down while I'm
different
there's lots of things you can do and
there's lots of valid things you do in
different waters to me the first thing
that makes you feel a bit uncomfortable
is this double negative down here how
our concern it's going to be coming from
straight right that's good now I said it
a few times being so whispered around
what will I do from here both sides yeah
I want to multiply through right so I'm
going to multiply both sides by X plus 3
like so I sorry I had to - don't just
measure them okay I've multiplied
through to get rid of the fraction
usually I have the wine on the left hand
side you know when we did this just the
second ago we put into MX plus B form so
put the one or less where I want it to
be I might as well I'll just
without changing I can expand and make
why the subjects you all they want you
right so why I get when I extend the
right hand side both have a good x - and
I might as well while I'm at it
add one to both sides to get Y on its
own since that makes it it's going to
balance it leave that for me okay and as
a confirmation of what we got for it's
really save on top because it's the same
question okay now this feels a bit
unfamiliar because we haven't done this
before okay
but now that you've done it we can
actually use this and do the do things
sort of straight away by looking at this
line here I want you look carefully at
that line and the original information
you must supply presence that - where
did that come from like go back chase
back through way to the to come from
it's a great plan so if I change this
grade it made it say like aha
you just change this to so a lot right
what about these numbers you where did
these come from
they came from these here right we're
just look carefully look at those
numbers again three negative one
what's the difference here they're the
opposite sign okay okay so this actually
came from our negative three and this
actually came from positive one so I can
summarize this I can say from this line
if you get given any gradient not just -
and any point not just this point I can
say on the left hand side I've got Y
minus the y-coordinate and on the right
hand side I've got and the gradient
that's an outside of X watch out - it's
Gordon that guy right there
that put a nice big colorful box around
is quite gradient for that get it wrong
if you like the white even mean it do
you mean like here here under them you
mean here anemia yes it does make a
difference because here once I get at
the end Y X being another bits that make
the equation of my life
so when you say y2 and x2 you mean a
specific point on like that point and
you have coordinates but here I mean
remember I said this could be any point
along my life so that's why I use X&Y
without any way vs. so this saves us a
lot of work we've got general form down
we've got gradient intercept form now
I've got point gradient for where if
you've got this different set of
information you can go there straight
away and look it takes one to three
lines if your supply with a point and a
gradient here's point gradient form now
you see it and you recognize it
you can quite this this big here you
don't need to prove it like we just did
you can go straight there and just
carefully look at the information you've
got substitute everything's good life
please I'm going to write the formula
straight away I'm going to write the
fall down you may find it useful when
you write down the information see how
there is moldy pigna to identify which
ones which gradient you what's that
going to substitute in to have a look at
this my view which what does it go into
and it's going to be the grade is this
guy here right so that'll be M negative
6 and for Arthur the x1y1 coordinate
right so I'm going to go x1 then y1 then
once you find up at a bedside where we
can go this you just let it up though
right
left-hand side why - what have a look oh
yeah there it is
there's y1 equals okay great
right there negative 1 outside of and
now I'm going to suggest just like we
need over here
even though you go straight to all this
is a plus there's a double menu
I currently actually write the minus and
the negative okay it will make sure we
do it right and you don't skip a step
and then you get computed why sure what
we don't tell you negatives it all right
I can add everything to both sides so I
add 4 to both sides so this is going to
be some lucky minus X minus 6 plus 4
what do you think that's all right I
expanded these brackets and I'm
subtracted added 4 to both sides and now
I can just tidy up - see what happened
over you - - very good for stop what for
me to sit by the way it's taller than
aim you know what this poem is this is
slope-intercept form right I'll have a
look at a question do they watch it in
there for or do they want it in some
other form so there one in general okay
does that easy
how do I change that to general folks
appreciate forward bring everything ok
yeah I just wanted you on the right hand
side so I'm going to cut everything for
the right to the left that means I'll
add X and I'll also add to it doesn't
leave your audience in it it really
doesn't matter but usually it's X plus
dy process that's the order you'll see
most frequently